and it's really great that this company
is matching now yeah I thought that was
weird too cuz like I do not need help in
the dating world you know I think he
means 401k matching has this ever
happened to you are you tired of looking
foolish and adult conversations do you
long for the days of no responsibility
well don't worry because we're here to
guide you I want to pick up some organic
salmon berries
adults love talking about obscure
vegetables meats and cheeses
give it a try yeah no me too I want some
jicama and okra good and Bologna ooh so
close you're gonna come to the at the
baby shower on Saturday right if you're
ever stuck like this
try saying you have another adult
obligation oh man you know I would I
would totally come but I have a
neighborhood council meeting great now
you're getting it so ever since then my
credit score has been good talk about
your credit score go on well I never
play it so I don't have a score it's not
a game
you want a melon farmers market dear to
fellow farmy oh yeah here's some other
words and phrases adults like to use we
should get brunch I love antique my back
has been killing me
has anybody tried flipping houses
compression tops fundraiser investments
taxes sunscreen well kids these days
electric exposed brick and now let's
practice what we've learned I think I
should have invested this vineyard hmm
you can do it swirl smell taste and
comment on the wine
till it tastes like pinecones yes I
sense that also from a tree I often
forget that pinecones come from trees
oh and don't forget adults have no idea
what they're saying either so the
squirrels are going for see you next
time